- Can you believe it?
The number one seat is upset.
Do you believe in miracles?
(playful music)
Sponsored by Indochino.
When we look back on
the unmitigated disaster
that was the COVID-19 pandemic,
there aren't gonna be
a lot of bright spots,
but perhaps one of the good
things to come out of it
is the preponderance of ridiculous videos
involving Zoom court hearings.
I mean, when you add
lawyers, judges, criminals,
and sometimes Florida man,
you're gonna get some ridiculous results.
So as we start to come
out of this whole thing,
let's rank them, and the good people
over at Above the Law
have done the hard work
and they have compiled
16 of the most ridiculous
epic Zoom fails that have
happened during the pandemic.
If you care about legal
industry insider news,
you should definitely be
reading AboveTheLaw.com,
led by commentators like Joe Patrice
and until recently, Elie Mystal,
two of my favorite legal
commentators out there.
(upbeat music)
So let's look at the sweet 16
of epic lawyer Zoom call fails
and see who comes out on top.
So we start with the number one seat,
I'm still not a cat
- [Judge] Mr. DuPont, and
I believe you have a filter
turned on in the video settings.
You might want to take a look.
- Oh, we're trying to,
can you hear me, judge?
- I can hear you, I think it's a filter.
- It is and I don't know how to remove it.
I've got my assistant
here, she's trying to,
but I'm prepared to go
forward with it best,
I'm here live, it's not, I'm not a cat.
- I must have seen this video
I don't know, a dozen times
and it still makes me laugh.
I'm still not a cat,
as if that actually needed
to be explained to the judge.
This is obviously the number one seat.
It's gonna be really tough
for any other Zoom fail
to top this one, the cat filter,
the sad eyes, the pleading
from the attorney.
It's just, it's just Zoom call perfection.
- I'm not a cat.
(upbeat music)
- This is a really, really tough matchup
for the 16 seat here,
which is just a letter
from a clearly exasperated
judge in Florida
saying that, look, you need
to show up for Zoom hearings
with some concern for how you look.
The judge is trying to have
some sort of decorum here,
reminding people not to wear
casual shirts and blouses,
that this is not just a
normal phone conversation
with their friends, and most importantly,
you have to wear at least
a shirt to a Zoom hearing.
(laughs)
I mean look, Florida lawyers
are going to Florida lawyer.
There's no getting around that.
It's like Syracuse
running its own defense.
And you know, they're
gonna do it every year.
Easily the number one
seat I'm still not a cat
defeating underdog the Westen
bar association of Florida.
- I'm prepared to go forward with it.
- All right, that takes
us to our next matchup,
and if you thought that it
wasn't possible to get any dumber
than Florida people
appearing in Florida court.
- Judge, you is so gorgeous,
judge, I just have to tell you.
- Well, Jeffrey Toobin
said, "hold my beer."
- According to press
reports, at some point,
Toobin engages in an intimate
act of self-gratification,
seemingly unaware that
a Zoom camera is on.
For his part, Toobin calls the incident
and embarrassing and stupid mistake.
- Yeah, I think we all remember
what happened to Jeffrey Toobin.
Many of you probably
have not seen the video,
so here is the uncensored video
of Jeffrey Toobin on a video call.
(loud crashing)
I'm obviously kidding.
I'm not going to show you that, but yeah,
always a good reminder that
you shouldn't cast stones
if you aren't prepared to walk the walk,
at least with pants.
So Jeffrey Toobin falls from grace.
He's up against the doctor who
appeared at a traffic court
while actually in surgery.
- So unless I'm mistaken,
I'm seeing a defendant
that's in the middle of an operating room,
appearing to be actively engaged in
providing services to a patient.
Is that correct, Mr. Green?
- Yes, sir.
- Yeah. This is terrifying.
- I do not feel comfortable
for the welfare of a patient
if you're in the process of operating
that I would put on a trial.
- Please, please, don't appear in court,
don't, whether it's on
Zoom or any other way,
if you're actively operating
on a person, this is crazy.
I covered this earlier
in the year, but my God,
what craziness had to be
going through this guy's head?
- I have another surgeon right here
who's doing the surgery with me,
so I can stand here and allow
them to do the surgery also.
- Look, if you have to reschedule,
if there's a medical
emergency, you can call up
the court clerk and you
can rearrange your hearing.
- I don't think so.
I don't think that's appropriate.
I think we're gonna have,
I'm gonna come up with a different date.
- This was a surprisingly tough matchup.
I understand why Jeffrey Toobin
was the number two seat here
but I have to say that I think the 15 seat
of doctor appearing in court
while actively potentially
harming a patient who was
undergoing cosmetic surgery.
Just the, it blows my
mind in such a way that
I think I'm gonna give it to the 15 seat.
Jeffrey Toobin is unseated,
(laughs) pun intended,
and we're gonna give it to the doctor
operating on a patient.
Just don't do that.
That is mindbogglingly crazy.
(upbeat music)
So that takes us to perhaps
the most prestigious
matchup of the tournament.
We have the oral argument
at the US Supreme Court
in which someone flushes a
toilet during the oral argument.
Let's see what happened here.
- [Lawyer] Marketing some other product.
Maybe they're gonna be saying,
"Hey, call your congressmen
and change the clause--"
- All right, so standard, boring
Supreme Court oral
argument, and then yeah.
(toilet flushes)
- [Lawyer] The subject matter
of the call ranges to the topic.
- Okay, that is very a
toilet being flushed.
- [Lawyer] The subject
matter of the call ranges--
- Oh boy, yeah.
I mean, I've been saying for
years that the Supreme Court
is going down the toilet.
(toilet flushes)
So the funniest thing about
this whole thing is that
the Supreme Court hates
the loss of decorum.
And this must have made
John Roberts's head explode
because he really cares
about these sorts of things.
Famously, you can't take a video camera
into the US Supreme Court,
so the fact that they
were finally allowing live
oral arguments, oh boy, at
least over Zoom calls like this,
it's just a, yeah, you can
imagine that the justices
were not happy about this at all.
So if the Supreme Court
toilet was up against
just your garden variety naked lawyer,
this time in California though,
not actually in Florida for once.
Yeah, so a guy that looks
like an '80s wrestler,
I think he actually
does have a mullet here.
That's sort of interesting.
He just appeared with no
clothes on whatsoever,
and then received
remonstrations from the judge.
This lawyer could really use a new suit
and tie and shirt and underwear.
- [Mysterious Voice] Indochino.
- Yeah, I mean, you know,
there's some heart going on with this one,
with just not bothering to put on clothes
for an oral argument, but
because of the prestige
of the Supreme Court, I'm handing it
to the number three seat easily.
A Supreme Court oral argument
while the toilet is
flushing wins this round.
All right, that brings
us to the final top seat
of this whole tournament.
We knew it was bound to happen.
That's with enough Zoom hearings
someone was going get it
on with the camera on.
And as it happened apparently in Peru,
that actually happened.
But after the hearing was over,
the cameras were still rolling
and the lawyer just, just got it on.
Yeah.
Well look, I mean,
people have urges, right?
I guess the worst part is that
this was actually happening
what appears to be the lawyer's office.
So that's just not good for
pandemic purposes either.
I mean, you know,
socially distance, yikes.
But that's up against
a real underdog here.
Just a tweet of what is assumed
to have happened during a Zoom hearing.
I had given an attorney some instructions
when he snapped "sneaky." (bleep)
I said, "sir, we can still hear you."
He clarified that his dog
had just pooped on the rug.
Yeah, a lot of heart in this one,
but we don't actually
know that they intended
this to be directed at the judge.
We presume that it was, but
perhaps it was just a mix up
and it's one of those
things where, you know,
the dog ate my homework or you know,
the dog pooped on the floor.
This one, no real contest.
You're gonna have to
give it to the lawyers
that are actually flaunting
all of the regulations
and the ethical requirements for lawyers
and just actually getting
it on in their offices.
Boy, yeah, easy win for
the number four seat.
So that takes us to our next matchup.
Here we have, oh, how do I put this?
Very aggressive oral argumentation here.
There is a female attorney at her desk,
but there seems to be
something going on just beneath
the desk that does not seem
to be on the up and up.
Again, these things are
bound to happen, but man,
you know, save it for after hours.
That is, the workplace is
not the right place for this.
And speaking of not the
right time or place,
we have the opponent,
another Zoom call where
they just decided not to
wear any clothes whatsoever.
- Your shenanigans, so
today's my Gonzaga Day,
and that's how it's done.
(all laughing)
Let's make sure everybody has clothes on.
- This one is a bit more
graphic in that they literally
stand up for apparently
no apparent reason.
And what makes this
particularly funny here though
is this as a civil procedure
class in law school,
where you would think that
they would know better.
And also why are people
just running around
all day long without clothes on?
Just put, put some pants on, man.
You'd think law students
would know better.
I'm gonna have to give
this to the law student.
That is incredibly embarrassing.
People keep saying, you
know, "put your clothes on."
And people are all audibly
distressed at what's going on.
- Come on, guys.
- No, your, your video is on.
- So I guess the second
upset of the tournament here.
That brings us to the Michigan
division of the tournament.
Here we have a man attends
a Zoom court hearing
from his own victim's home.
I mean, this is, this is some craziness.
- Your Honor, I have
reason to believe that
the defendant is in the same apartment
as the complaining witness right now,
and I'm extremely scared for her safety.
- And then they realized
that both the alleged abuser
and the alleged victim
are in the same location.
- I want you to walk out
to the front of the house,
show me the house number on the house.
- There is some order, a
restraining order basically,
that says they can't be
anywhere near each other.
- Your Honor, me and (bleep)
both don't want the no contact.
I ask that that be dropped.
I'm sorry I lied to you.
- Yeah, and then they argue that
they don't want this order to be in place.
And the police come and arrest this guy
for violating this restraint order.
- [Judge] Take the
cigarette out of your mouth.
The hearing is adjourned.
- Man. That's crazy.
I mean, this happens in Michigan
in exactly the same courtroom
as the judge in the opponent
where the guy is attending
a suspended license hearing
from actually being in a car.
- What I'm struggling with
is the driving suspended.
I believe you drove to wherever you are
in the vehicle you're in,
and you're dumb enough to come on video
with you sitting in the
driver's seat of a vehicle.
What would you like me to know, sir?
- That I'm not sending my own vehicle
and I didn't drive here,
that I'm sitting in my boss's vehicle
currently because I'm in court.
I wasn't trying to do court
in a customer's house.
- I mean, you expect this
sort of behavior from teams
from Florida, but from not from Michigan.
I mean kudos to Judge Middleton here,
who seems to handle this with
with confidence and respect.
But this guy is saying
a whole bunch of crap
in his own courtroom.
Both of these things
happened with the same judge
and the same prosecutor, incredible.
I'm gonna have to give this to, boy,
the victim and abuser
being in the same house.
That's crazy.
I'm glad that there was a good result
with the police coming by
and extricating the guy from this house.
But that's uh, boy, that is unusual.
You don't see that every
day or every tournament.
- This is a issue we didn't have
when we were having live court.
- All right, that brings us to
the food and pajamas division.
The first up is the lawyer
fails to turn off his camera
while he's eating lunch.
Now that doesn't sound too bad,
but let's see what's going on here.
Yeah, so he is just, he's
going to town on that lunch.
He is, boy, yeah.
You know, you'd think
you would just, you know,
wait until the hearing is over.
Who knows if the judge is going to ask you
to actually say something
while you're chomping down
on a sandwich, I think.
Not best practices.
You know, if you're in front of the judge,
you probably should not be scarfing down
on an enormous lunch for this entire time.
Put the sandwich away!
- The sandwich.
(laughing)
- All right, versus a
lawyer being reprimanded
for not wearing a tie and more.
Here we have (laughs) an
ex parte communication.
So you're not allowed to talk to the judge
or send emails to the judge alone.
If you're going to do that,
you have to copy opposing counsel on it.
And the judge says "the email states that
I would not consider
an application from him
because he was quote,
was not wearing a tie.
That is true, as the record reflects.
What the record also
reflects is that Mr. Weisbrot
appeared in court for trial via Zoom
on Tuesday in either a
printed t-shirt or pajamas.
It was difficult to discern."
Yeah, so if you object that
the judge is reprimanding you
for not wearing a tie and
you are in fact wearing
either a preprinted t-shirt or pajamas,
you probably don't have
the better of the argument.
And maybe you should not
be complaining to the judge
that you're being reprimanded
for going to court tieless.
I'm just gonna go out on a limb there.
I'm gonna give this to
scarfing down lunch.
That's hilarious, and it's,
my God, it's still going.
Put the lunch away, man. Geez.
So we're, you know, I
guess as the equivalent
of overtime in this tournament. (laughs)
- The sandwich.
(laughing)
- All right, so that brings us to
the top law school bracket here.
We have on the one hand, the
comments from a professor
- A lot of my lower ones are Blacks.
Happens almost every semester.
- Yeah, I think we've
seen this comment before.
That's um, that is a very
unfortunate way of phrasing that.
And that's really too
bad, versus Harvard Law.
The federal society president
apparently brings a gun
to class and I can't
imagine how bad that could.
Oh my God. (repeated bleeps)
Why would you do that?
Ah, ooh boy.
I'm just gonna say that both of these
are completely disqualified
from participating
in the law school bracket
now and in the future.
So that's just a, that's a DQ all around.
All right, so now we just need to
figure out the elite eight.
So here we have still not a cat
that handily beats the disqualified
Georgetown and Harvard
bracket, so they advance,
and then we have the afternoon delight
versus the Civ Pro streaker.
I'm gonna give it to the Civ Pro streaker
just because they were
so incredibly clueless.
Ben, get your stuff together, man.
(class laughing uncomfortably)
- Ben!
- Come on, guys.
- Are you attending to
Civ Pro completely naked?
So Civ Pro streaker advances.
Then we have, let's see code
blue versus a man's got to eat.
So this is the sandwich
versus the doctor in the ER, tough call.
Tough call, but I'm gonna
give it to the underdog again,
the doctor in the operating room.
Yeah, attending a call
while you're in surgery,
that's malpractice, whereas eating a lunch
in front of the judge,
that's just mal-sandwich.
Then we have the SCOTUS toilet flush
versus catching an abuser in the same home
as the alleged victim here.
I mean, that's, that's so sad.
I'm just gonna have to give it again
to the Supreme Court toilet flush here.
Again, purely based on
it making John Roberts,
the chief justice's head explode here.
He must have absolutely hated that.
I think that they get extra points
for the lack of decorum
at the Supreme Court.
So the Supreme Court
toilet flush advances.
Okay, things are really
starting to heat up here.
We have still a cat let's
check in on the floor.
Mr. Attorney, are you still a cat?
- I'm here live, I'm not a cat.
- He is still a cat.
Ladies and gentlemen,
still a cat versus Civ Pro.
Ben. Ben, can you hear us?
Ben, did you get your (bleep) together?
(laughing)
No, Ben can't hear us.
So still not a cat advances to the finals.
That brings us a doctor who should not be
having a Zoom hearing
in the operating room
versus the Supreme Court toilet flush.
Doctor, have you stopped
operating on your patient?
- I have another surgeon right here
who is doing the surgery
with me so I can stand here
and allow them to do the surgery also.
- Ooh, that's gonna cost him.
And the Supreme Court,
is there still a working
toilet in the Supreme Court?
- [Lawyer] The subject matter of the call
(toilet flushes)
ranges to the topic.
- Yes, there is still a toilet,
The Cinderella story of
the Supreme Court toilet
advances to the finals.
So that takes us to the finals.
We have still a cat who's let me check in.
Are they still a cat?
Yes, they are still a cat.
- I've got my assistant here.
She's trying to, but uh.
- Versus the Supreme Court toilet.
Let's check in, ladies and gentlemen,
is there still a toilet
at the Supreme Court?
(toilet flushes)
Yes. Yes, my God., they've done it.
There is still a toilet
at the Supreme Court.
They've done it!
(squeaks)
The Cinderella story throughout
this entire tournament.
Do you believe in miracles and
toilets at the Supreme Court?
The team that made the chief
justice's head explode,
they have done it.
My goodness, March madness
is incredible every year.
The Supreme Court oral
argument toilet wins
for the first time in history.
Just incredible.
(toilet flushes)
And if we've learned
anything from these lawyers,
it's that wearing a suit to court,
or any clothes at all is
more important than ever.
And all of my suits come from Indochino,
including this one that
I'm wearing right now.
It was custom made just for me.
And by the way, if you've ever wondered
which particular suits I'm wearing,
you can actually click on the
link below in the description
and see the entire Legal
Eagle collection at Indochino.
It has all of my suits.
You can actually get the exact same fabric
and customize it for yourself,
because if you can't tell,
I'm thrilled that Indochino is back.
They are my favorite, and
whether you are returning to work
and need a new suit that fits
after the COVID 19 pounds,
or if you're going
through with that wedding
that you postponed and
all of the groomsmen
need matching tailored suits,
Indochino is 100% the way to go,
and Mazel Tov by the way.
Because the secret to a great
suit is all about the fit,
and I'm a reasonably athletic
guy, but I can never buy suits
off the rack because they
just simply never fit right.
If the shoulders fit,
the waist is too small.
It either doesn't fit
or it costs a ton to have a tailor fix it.
But with Indochino you can send
in your measurements online
or you can go to one of
their hundreds of stores
and have a stylist take your
particular measurements.
And a couple of weeks
later, you will get a box
with the best fitting
suit of your entire life,
just right out of the box.
And if there are any issues,
they will tailor it until it
fits perfectly, all for free.
And when I used to buy suits off the rack,
I used to spend hundreds
just on the tailoring alone,
but with Indochino they
will make you a fully custom
tailored suit specifically
for you for less than $399.
And the best part is they
still use the best materials,
like super 140s wool.
I personally will never get
another off-the-rack suit again,
and once you try Indochino,
neither will you,
and Legal Eagles will
get a special $30 off
of any purchase of $399 or more
when you click on the link below
and enter the code LegalEagle at checkout.
I cannot overstate how great
having a custom suit is,
and getting a custom suit for these prices
is a complete no brainer.
So just click on the link below
and use the code LegalEagle at checkout.
Plus clicking on that link
really helps out this channel.
And by the way, if you
do get an Indochino suit,
tag me in a photo on Twitter.
I love seeing how fly all
of you Legal Eagles look.
So do you agree with my analysis?
Leave your objections in the comments
and check out this playlist over here
with all of my other real law reviews,
where I talk about "Home Alone," "Suits,"
"My Cousin Vinny," you name
it, it's all right here.
So click on this playlist
and I'll see you in court.